re was hast du schon wieder und ich habe
gerade das war ein melonen schiff nach
es ist das dach des tages nur weil er
aus albanien kommt es lauter wenn er
flüsterte normal redet alter werden mit
der zeit verstehen warum vergeben ich
meine ich hab sofort verstanden
wir haben jetzt eine note und jetzt
müsst ihr einfach dass es ist egal in
welches feiert das papier lege annehmen
muss uns erst gelegen revue ins erste
liegende zweite noch nicht ins dritte
langer zeit zu beschriften
ich weiß aber nicht was ich nehme was
euch denn neben walter von lucadou
behinderte jüngere dir was nicht passt
konnten die zwei wellensittiche
überlegen ja ich hab was gut ist okay
dass durch hätte
wie komme ich jetzt heraus wie komme ich
jetzt hier raus machen
er tritt wo bist du hier komm ich raus
aus den kammern wie creative zwei alter
wie soll ich das meiste ja ich weiß was
ich musste die fenster wieder dahin
bauen weil ich habe jetzt das aus dem
anderen dispenser genommen
dass das papierchen muss auf jeden fall
wieder aktiv sein damit man weiß was zu
bauen muss es also ich muss also das
ding wieder zurücklegen
ja genau mache da ist schon jemand
fertig bauen
ok ich muss jetzt aufbauen was das
papier wieder raus meinte die sollten
wir wieder rein tun habe ich nicht
richtig erklärt ich wünsche mir ja ich
komplett abruzzen jung ich muss einfach
mal dass das schiff bei mir und es soll
einfach ganz blöder pizza alter ich
hasse dich ich habe das von dem ich
glaube ich habe das von denen ich bin
sooo geil alter also ohne witze sieht
richtig gut oder es bis jetzt alles
falsch gemacht
jetzt muss er wieder zurück in das
fenster
fertig ich habe rausgenommen ausgenommen
ich hab' ich habe mein papi nicht zurück
tun können was machen ein stück scheiße
bei mir hey was man jetzt machen wir das
erraten hat einfach so machen wir das
erraten hat
ich könnte ich könnte raten wäre das das
ist doch nicht ob mein okay es ist
entweder hinten sind oder hitler
hinsehen oder hitler junge aber ich
denke wenn ich mit euch viele hundert
prozent was rechtsradikales dabei
was ist das bei mir dein glück nur drin
meinte macht alles kaputt
behindert ich glaube muss
wem gehört dass hier das wo wir alle
sind so austritt also wer muss das
erraten nicht dass
eine atombombe sein
ich muss atompilzen geschrieben da
spielt das mache ich alter winzen
ich habe mich dafür entschieden ich
dachte ich sage doch noch vorher wind
sind oder hitler alter
bizeps einem gesicht das alter des tages
das bereitet mir geschrieben was des
tages
ich möchte anmerken
gehen wir also dass das leck gewusst
dass es so einfach nicht
dollar
unvergesslich die comments by -regelung
von craft ist bereits in diese welt zu
spielen